oh yeah have you been doing any
sprinting work now you're looking for
then yeah you're looking if you're not
gonna win you're not gonna make on down
16 pounds 16 16 so now you weigh 155 yep
255 yep okay so when you more play that
last that last 20 it's gonna be a
[ __ ] my able to help you out
what do you got here like a steam room
okay no slim fast no slim slow where is
your where your problem areas my dick
takes up most of my weight okay
we know that where's the other problem
area see are you were the most
uncomfortable with my ass of a fat ass
mm-hmm like pH fat when you took your
shirt off when you platinum UFC I know
you were those self-conscious you
talking about my teeth right yeah watch
me a little but not crazy about your
paunch parliament's I really want to use
that word I've never used Orleans Punk
no you've never used the word pawn no
okay I just feel like I don't like
anything that dude alright so but let's
just say you have a paunch step okay a
little tum tum tum tum tum tum to eat
them right okay so as you are ensuring
don't have it at 285 big chests nothing
else on something I'll have it at 2/3
the hardest thing to lose I have a
little something for you given to me
sent to me sent to you sent to me in
mail probably illegal in a black case or
what anavar I got a whole month ahead of
our of them
I got a month's worth of anavar and it's
the real reason why there's so much you
need to get longer a month early and of
our burns belly fat now I'm not gonna
take it but why don't you want to take
like you don't get rid of that nut sac
underneath your chin what you like the
throat scrotum
you don't wanna get rid of left I'm
sorry I'm sorry you get same punch
I've been insecure about that for the
past month yeah I know you have this is
do I have that now I mean I mean your
throat looks like my grandma's oh oh my
god but back to do you thing you want do
you want to inject Anna bar right
I am NOT talking about anything else
yeah has this been like in your head for
a while I had it I had it ready to go
right back fun of me make my wheels up
but I do now yeah my wheels off getting
the kitchen bro let's dig in though I
keep my chin down huh yeah I know you
think they just like this really your
name man daddy knows what's up bro ain't
too long dawg chin bring up plastic
surgery I want my lids done about my
little [ __ ] gross cobbler time how
[ __ ] dare what dude you look like a
toad I'm insecure and how I'm not
insecure about mush but now I can't care
about that because everyone looks at
your throat that is amazing
dude that could be you look at you on
the left that's me on the right Road oh
my god man you got that yet that frog do
you get the Frog bro who we call it oh
my god like I just looks like you got a
flush turtleneck I'll get that look
that's a big difference
dude that's like date I mean different
woman on the right but whatever oh that
that's a good one
it could be you bro that's impressive
back to me though what's up with this
anavar son and how do we know it's trust
worth it's trustworthy
I guess positive real dude who's really
ill true but I need like long in a month
if I'm gonna look like [ __ ] we're gonna
start with on and I'm gonna do you a
solid I'm gonna call a couple of my
friends who work with pro athletes and
do this stuff I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get exactly what you need to do really
typical typical animal only cyclone
elastomer four to six weeks
oh she will run it I think that's a
steroid turn run it I'm gonna Ray
hey after what I'm doing you're gonna
have a cycle span I was doing dude
that's what I'm doing what you doing
running some gear what does that mean
you know you're there well I don't
understand letting some gear bro oh
you're running gear running gear in
other words she's doing some anavar
it is it pillar injection uh its pill
have you ever done anything kind of a
steroid ever
nothing never done like could afford it
when I was fighting would have
definitely done it like that up together
the top everybody when you were fighting
everybody was doing it I know that's the
secret would you say 95% of the people a
back in the day now it's all different
yeah Anna was one of the most expensive
anabolic steroids in the market 60
tablets can cost up to $150 I'll take 10
come on baby
hey let me ask you this ten weeks do you
think I had a gun to your head this is
gonna put you in some hot water if I had
a gun to your head do you think that
Costa and ul I'm not answering
okay I understand why you're not it's
not fair to you I think they're running
I think they're running game somebody
said these guys are running gear would
you go to the head if somebody can't see
you right Brennan
those guys are running here would you go
would you go oh my god
I would I would gun to the head I've got
my gun to your head and it's like dude
if you're wrong we're gonna kill you
I'd say yes you would say yes and how is
it that they get away with it I mean
that's II they they are just paula
koklos them it looked way better than
your room man he was bigger
he looked healthy you look phenomenal
money holiday 28:28 I mean 25 and 42
year old you all's phenomenal a lot of
people I have you well winning that
fight I didn't you didn't I mean you can
give either way I don't know how they're
doing I don't know but you're saying gun
to the head
I'm I always assume guys are on it but I
don't Kosta was caught twice with that
IV thing so mm-hmm
car with the IV thing yeah look man I
don't take a thing which might be the
best body I think's I mean it he is a
handsome devil all you names the eraser
what he doing dude just call yourself
the best looking guy in the world no
dude parlor the BOD cause yeah Paulo the
best-looking guy in the world Costa
what's the problem odd no that's the BOD
look at that [ __ ] I'm the BOD I'm not I
guarantee you you all beat them in the
dick game though I heard he just got the
Cuban missle down I'm sure he does real
crisis I'm sure he does now talking
about oh but he's back to Miami bar yeah
Paulo coast after six weeks yeah like I
wonder how much Jesus Christ I don't
know how much of change you get you know
from Anibal your body's gonna look
exactly like I'm gonna look like then
six weeks I wonder if it's just mild
change you know like yeah I don't know
what I was going to say we'll see what
happens I'm in my body just eats it up
and I look like [ __ ] the rock you
might and then I'm like the next I think
you would I think if you did the COS
teres he's doing you want haha oh my god
there's other [ __ ] going on with this
[ __ ] Yoker what first of all that's
years down the road because we get along
as here is in the right big deal yeah
that's a lot of that's a holy [ __ ]
totally with a necklace like that dude I
don't think I should do that bro I do
cuz I'm dude Hollywood threw in the ski
you know I've always wanted to I'm gonna
look like Thor you've always wanted to
be shredded that's what happens that's a
stretching up a lot of the women a lot
of the female CrossFit athletes all of
them do have are yeah I've heard a lot
of the IG models you see with like
blonde ass and stuff they do anavar
really yeah get that stomach I met a guy
by met a guy who knows his way around
the the gear the gear steroids for the
kid cares up the Garen you use tell me
he's like dude nine times ten kilos
chicks ear like you really shred all the
time to a lot of them run Anna barking
super mild supermodel is he can do
anything for a [ __ ] jack-o'-lantern
like me I want to see what happens cuz
your receptors are wide open I know a
lot about steroid talk why don't hear
your bro your receptors are wide open
your your lats it's gonna be interesting
to see what happens to you because
you're so bam bam strong to begin with
like doing a little [ __ ] like I
wonder if your test is low if your test
is well I can't imagine if you did test
do although everybody can [ __ ] what they
say now is that a lot of times you'll go
oh my testosterone is low do you know
that high levels of mercury or low
levels of zinc you can have a huge
effect on your testosterone and when you
bring that or some people just don't
sleep much and if you're not sleeping
you're a [ __ ] did you sleep pretty
good yeah dude I'm gonna look like these
everybody I look like
[ __ ] Corbett thought that guy I'm ready
off a better start for them God he got
shred city yeah I don't believe it's
just an apart with those guys but who
knows it's a strict diet - I think that
looks dumb some of it is just like oh
there you go the American flag
I see no change sir a different angle
and different lighting hey John can you
put your tits up dude should I start
doing an or that's me on the left right
now well we need to do a little doctor
talk - oh no I don't have to get off
isn't I think it's the wrong order
no that's very weird chin if it would
did what's the what's the car looking
human being everyone told me I do anavar
and clen and what clenbuterol it's
called a clear bra it's no shot that
clear clears a rub bra everyone clear
the clearest clenbuterol no it's not
broken up
cleanse cleanse cleanse bureau the
clears the I heard the Klan I get your
uh what Barry Bonds was taken apparently
no he's not dude he was Clem just cut
like type of increases you're the fan
what the [ __ ] it does bro who do you
have any questions my stairs you talk to
me no I got I looking at
Kabira isn't a steroid but has some
property similar to those of Amla such
as promoting increased muscle mass check
yeah dude these properties Cambria has
been used in livestock to increase the
amount of lean muscle well I can buy it
right it would call that into clear the
heart rate blood pressure clean will by
increasing the heart rate blood pressure
that ain't good that's not going to
crease the metallic energy and overall
body temps caused by to burn more energy
dude people sweat on it it's good stuff
yeah I sweat a lot already they cause
cardiac hypertrophy enlarged heart of
petrol stairs for my heart damage okay
yeah anything get the Shred City you
know you have to everybody know you
don't want to do that you're a big guy
you don't need to [ __ ] with your heart
like that and I need to look in there
anavar apparently doesn't cause Toyota
supers you don't want to be drinking on
a dude if if those IG [ __ ] can do it
you don't think I can yeah you can all
this acne not too worried about any of
that I could actually use some thinner
I hear up drinkin class schools this
main ones worse side effects not because
I'm a big tap you dude big balls is nice
I'm gonna call I'm gonna call my buddy
who works with this stuff a lot it ever
has lower and tragic effects in others
that's why you would like your boss see
what I were tell you this whatever two
people you take stories when you [ __ ]
everything like no you actually lower
sex drive so yeah that's why you would
like experience a lower sex drive
tiredness even muscle lost after stop Oh
after stopping okay it's more pronounced
if you bunk with their around other
stars at the same time but but I would
need some side out some sort of post
cycle that means that run gear after oh
I'm sorry you got it you gotta bring
back to your normal levels right right
well high blood cholesterol it changed
the way your body house fat increases
your bad cholesterol while decreasing
your good cos all those how do you know
it's all about I don't know it's all
about using a little bit ultra
moderation yeah it's all about y'all
reading it out worrying about you
thought about getting shredded not
worrying about the yeah well let's see
what happens oh I would assume Anna bars
better for you then cut the bread is
dying
xiety ants inside I would say it's
better than whiskey and I drink tonight
I drink whiskey I feel great welcome
with a headache side effects and women
if you're women you will grow dick with
a good oh forget about having kids at
least but not last anyone can take down
if you want to have someone call you
daddy those you're for truly right okay
that's a bad one well like you always
get it back take post psycho stuff even
even if anniversaries didn't run the
same as Hannah bollocks terrors be used
there must be better options out there
right that was my number one question
for a very long time until I found oh
this is a ad for some bride body ah and
for all a safe and legal matter
god damn it they got Kalyn my god me got
you do this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
Oh [ __ ] business